zara you are literally my hero
[Music]
well first up um we're not the first to
do this but we're not gonna miss out on
the party of congratulating rihanna and
asap
entertainment rocky reports
they're expecting their first child and
they were seen out in new york this
weekend baby bump out and they snapped
this dreamy pick right here in harlem
the place where asap rocky grew up how
can rihanna look so good
hello i mean when i come home from a
happy hour after having like three
nuggets i don't look that good this
woman is pregnant creating another human
and look how gorge i know but it's so
rihanna it's so hard to do this i i just
i'm so happy for her too she's such a
good person and her
i i'm i'm just i was thrilled to see
this and the fact that it was like in
his home and there's a picture where
he's just kissing her head and
it just made me so happy i know they're
so cute and you know i will say the fans
online though have been waiting like
when is when is she gonna drop an album
when is it gonna happen it's about nine
more months i think you might have to
wait she's gonna drop a baby first and
then maybe a new one dropping something
for sure
insider reports singer charlie puth
revealed his pal elton told him quote
those songs you put out in 2019 were no
good and he said that elton had it right
he was working with too many
collaborators and he kind of lost
himself with everybody else and he just
needed a little reset um bridgette do
you have the hard-hitting friends and do
you like that oh yeah you know um a lot
of people know i'm good friends with amy
schumer and she's very direct she gets
to the point and i appreciate that you
know a lot of times but sometimes i also
just want to be you know wrapped up in a
drew ross sandwich
oh no i think it's important some of the
most crucial points in my life is when
someone who loved me told me i was doing
it wrong or doing something wrong or not
being the best version of myself and it
was tough man it's a gut punch when you
hear that but when you look back if you
listen to those people that love you
it'll change your life right well just
like in movie uh in the movie rudy
they helped move you down the field by
giving you the ball you know you got to
take the ball rash and you really got to
run with this you know so
it's really about
i'm like stop talking can you help
everything could go back to rudy it's a
perfect movie i would like to challenge
you every news story if you could bring
it back to rudy somehow today
that's not a challenge that's a that's
an invitation all right
okay first up we've got news about two
of staten island's finest the new york
times reports
snl's pete davidson and colin jones just
pitched in to buy an old ferry boat they
were part of a group of investors who
spent 280 000 on the decommissioned
ferry with the dream of turning it into
an entertainment venue the boat is named
john f kennedy and it first hit the
river in 1965.
it's a real floating piece of new york
history
ross
are you on board oh drew now oh i'm so
proud of you that was a great pun
that was great you know i i actually
love this because you think about this
they grew up there probably riding that
ferry into the city with big dreams
their whole childhood and now they they
went and bought it and they're turning
it into a business it's going to be like
a comedy club you heard of the the love
boat this is the laugh boat you know and
they're they're investing their their
real money i just hope they can keep
this business afloat
well we've got one incredible teen who
just made aviation history this story
moves me so much okay cnn reports 19
year old zara rutherford has become the
youngest woman to fly around
the world
solo this brave young pilot spent
260 hours in flight with stops in 41
countries for a distance of 32 000 miles
she faced weather
visa delays stuck in alaska and russia
got banned from china's airspace but for
five months she did this wow and then
she landed full circle to her home in
belgium her first stop was her favorite
sandwich shop a girl after my own heart
you're like
changing the world and breaking records
but you're still thinking about that
hometown sandwich
can you imagine
your friend your sibling anyone you know
accomplishing something like this she
she was over siberia and the winds were
so crazy she was scared like it was her
most fearful apparently she flew over
the atlantic and the clouds were so bad
she had to fly
1500 feet above water wow for nine hours
straight what
type of bravery this zara you are
literally my hero
[Music]
you